before this video begins this video is
going to be played in half the speed so
for you to watch it properly hit 2x on
your brows that I should work even if
you're on a phone or if you are on a
computer this is not a desperate ploy
for me to increase my watch time it's
because I need to destroy taste every I
can't believe this day finally came my
own audience my own 9 year olds have
turned against me how could this happen
what led this to happen don't know what
I'm talking about or look at this top 10
mysteries science still can't answer I
do not look like Bigfoot freaking stop
it and if I had legs then where are they
so stupid I'm gonna tell Susan on you
guys guys don't understand think I'm
playing if we get this to Lula why Felix
has to say what he's soul oh this is
from the the last video word right okay
alright I'll tell you guys in the next
video
this 100 million likes leave your
clothes
[Music]
so this one watching College GameDay for
Michigan Ohio State today okay we're
back
we're friends again it's friendship is
back lahum proudly he looks like he's
holding that he's fighting for he knows
he's fighting for a good cause that's
what I see in that man's eyes that
nine-year-old side the burning passion
what is it College GameDay subscribe to
peopIe see this is what I'm talking
about with everyone doing their part and
even doing your part
I thought that I had a new idea I got a
new idea to stop T series right now
everyone oh I I gotta tell you guys
about this by the way Devi 504 absolute
man Ladd is playing big for Sonia
[Music]
this is what I'm talking about everyone
doing their parts you just wanna get
there stop at least this one makes sense
cause he hides what doesn't exist
my legs top 10 myths this ends oh my god
stop even the grocery safety why why why
can I not leave my house without getting
ridiculed is enough being made fun of
every single day with my channel
addition to make this the new icon
that's pretty cool actually I guess you
guys really like the white hair didn't
you as they got the white Pew news hat
Takashi's 6-9 whole squad full of
killers I'm an effing killer too
district is hurt oh man I really want to
catch it to come out of jail not because
he's innocent or maybe it did something
bad but I really want him on me Revere
oh I'll call some people I have some
connections they could probably release
takashi would my influence I have a lot
of subscribers you know that's how that
works
I made a script that unsub's to t-series
when injected with this USB what is this
real
okay
[Music]
it opens up Start menu Explorer oh now
you know it's fake no one uses Internet
Explorer
hahaha ok it up is empty series and then
[Music]
is it gonna do it
oh my god
this changes right shipping nice
producing ship it is free bugs and
pargana
and sent to India free pubs and begun
but that only USB and send it to India
this will change everything
this is what it this is what I mean
this is what I'm talking about everyone
doing their part
everyone just stop bullying we could
stop T is avery geez guys something is
happening why did that male feminists
break into my office and why is he
matching my chair so well all I gotta
say guys we need to laughs for like
another two to two weeks so I have just
we have time to finish off that would be
great nine year olds we need five
millions to buy Super Ball go fund me
mr. B's you know huge has 5 million
ridiculous why should I pay for my own
channel when other people can do the
work for me that's how it works in life
truly epic style hey look that's where
my legs went maybe I'll be tracer
I'm already tracer maybe I wanna help
baby pie I'm already not helping this is
so extremely why is Marc Ange a complier
tonight a helping hand
it's now or never my dudes it's been
there for a while I'm a sever stiffly
that's really cool design for teachers I
look cool jisu is lame what is wrong
with me can I just be normal for a
second Smosh losing the most subscribed
title welcomes that you first plays
Felix losing the Mersenne fan taro makes
a bunch of videos about it hey guys I
don't actually care about his series to
be honest
that's why I make so many videos about
it because I don't care it doesn't
matter to me okay I all unless we don't
care of T series wins
to be fair I really like this one but
can you do this how does that mean still
there
I can't wait for like eight years from
now one when can you do this we'll just
come back us a best natural cycle of a
meme and it's like at least eight years
for any meme to come back on ironically
ironically and ironically this meme as
reaches peak yes I think I think it's
time to stop finally we have pants that
fit me well everyone knows I don't have
legs Kowalski analysis okay again if
legs existed then where the Frick are
they subscribe to pretty pie what an
absolute legend this is one talking
about Indians helping out and
understanding that this is not about
countries this is not about right and
wrong and who's more attractive
who's not that great in general this is
about it's about some things bigger oh
[Applause]
look at this look at this here's someone
doing their part again I'm doing my part
I work at an ice cream shop and
convinced my bye boss to change one of
the flavor names to brofist and give
evil 10% of the purchase if if the
subscribe to PewDiePie one increase
revenue in your local business just add
brofist flavor g and one of our brofist
flavor tastes like put your own family
and livelihood aside just goddamn second
and stop thinking about yourself for a
goddamn second and help me out here okay
gosh is six-nine gonna come out of jail
in 50 years like this is so sad hashtag
free Takashi
so he can be part of meme review please
guys can we make this happen
if this video gets 500,000 up odds then
takashi will be released from jail mark
my freaking words just kidding I got the
DD to play shyffilis I'm in the club I
mean if that is not doing your part I
don't know what is
[Music]
[Applause]
said no one at the club it's a fire
song man like I I get I get down at the
club the reinforcements have a ride
everyone promote everyone promote this
video in every way possible of course I
thought how could I know I did not
forget I did not forget mr. B's guardian
angel of this channel recorded himself
for 12 hours saying pity pie a hundred
thousand
[Music]
ha ha yes by the way is my second
account that's why I'm not subscribed of
course watch this video leave it on so
he gets a lot of watch time is for you
to promote this idea right
now I command you just a reminder that
future still hasn't made a half speed
video telling us to watch it in two
times be okay right this time for doing
it this time were freakin doing it in my
last desperate attempt to increase watch
time to get more views and subscribers
we're freakin doing this I made a
website for who P ceases
professional apologizer skills opposed
to chasing breathing t-series well you
know what can I do for you write an
apology I can write an apology which is
perfect for you needs it will be concise
fresh anymore too poorly whoa all right
looks like my plan beef YouTube fail has
finally been sordid look at that
the urban legend says that if you climb
three times in the wall my harem rule
parking lot with the grocery car at 3:00
a.m. and say me review fuse appears guys
yeah see best stop memeing this boy hey
Felix I have trouble sleeping in Nice so
what I usually do is I put a live top
and grab my toilet tablet and started to
drawing last night the first thing that
came to mind before I started drawing
was a toad it's awesome like these
anniversary's coming up god bless you
sleepy wears headphones while viewing
memes forgets to put them on play this
one game his pace was strongest man
contest churches
I make feeling play look funny another
love why YouTube's favorite show I'm
just kidding it's my favorite show I
loved recording these I'm so proud of
you guys for all the effort and
literally everyone you're getting
involved with this teasers thing a joke
or not it's really fun and I love seeing
it so thank you and also check our merch
if you want link in description you can
order now and get it before Christmas
and that's it for me for now namaste
I don't got to go say much and goodbye